قيادات الحزب الديمقراطيه تحاول التركيز
على انجازات اداره بيدن والصرف الانظار عن
اقصى يسار الحزب السعي انصبا خلال الايام
الاخيره على الوسائل الوسطيه والابتعاد عن
مقترحات الجناح التقدممي التي قد يستغلها
الجمهوريون للهجوم على الحزب الديمقراطي
خلال الحملات الانتخابيه تعامل
الديمقراطيون بقوه اكبر مع قضايا مثل
الجريمه والاقتصاد مع الاعتراف بمخاوف
الناخبين مثلا تفاخر بيضا بخلق ملايين
الوظائف الجديده وانخفاض معدل البطاله
واستثمار المليارات في البنيه التحتيه
واشنطن بوست نقلت عن محللين ديموقراطيين
قولهم ان هذه الرسائل هدفها الابقاء على
قاعده المؤيدين وايضا جذب الناخبين
الموجودين في الوسط او على الحياد الصحيفه
واضافت ان الناخبين المترددين يبقون في
حاله الترجح لعده اسباب منها انهم يعتبرون
ان افكاره هي مزيج من الحزبين الرئيسيين
وبشكل عام يميل هذا النوع لدعم الحزب الذي
لا يكون في السلطه وهو الامر الذي تكرر
خلال العقود الماضيه هو مدعى اليه ايضا
الى ماسك قبل ساعات بدعوى الحفاظ على
توازن السلطه
مع اقتراب الانتخابات نحن امام سعد قليله
فقط يعود التخوف للواجهه من عدم قبول
المرشحين نتائج الانتخابات حاله خسارتهم
كما فعلتم سابقا العديد من المرشحين
الحاليين للانتخابات مثلا رفضوا الافصاح
عامه اذا كانوا سيقبلون النتيجه وتراوحت
الردود بين عدم التعليق على السؤال او
الجزم بالفوز وحينها قبول نتيجه
الانتخابات اي قبول النتيجه فقط اذا فاز
المرشح هل سيقبل جمهوريون بنتيجه
الانتخابات سؤال طرح على رئيسه اللجنه
الوطنيه للحزب رونالاك دانيال التي قالت
ان مرشحين حزبها سيقبلون بالنتائج سواء
فازوا ام لا معبره عن رغبتها بان تجرى
الانتخابات
الرئاسيه قبل عامين كما نذكر روج الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب مع حلفائفه لمزاعم
بان الانتخابات قد سرقت حتى ان ترامب لم
يعترف حتى الان بهزيمته في الانتخابات
امام بيدن وعدد ترامب امس للخطاب ذاته
خلال جوله انتخابيه في فلوريدا واعاد
مزاعم سرقه الانتخابات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على الجانب الاخر انتقد بيدن وجود اكثر من
300 من المرشحين الجمهوريين لمختلف
المناصب ممن ينكرون نتيجه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2020 اعتبر ايضا ان تهديدات
بعض مرشحين الجمهوريين برفض قبول نتائج
الانتخابات اذا خسروا تشكل تهديدا
للديمقراطيه ملقيا باللوم على ترامب الذي
يروج لمزاعم سرقه الانتخابات
برنامج